who is Jessie Faden why does she seem
both lost-and-found on her first day as
director at the Federal Bureau of
control how can she possibly maintain
her composure in the face of the
haunting ethereal and material
distortions that have overtaken the
bureau you may only have some answers to
these questions by the time controls
credits appear while being vague or
opaque could be viewed as a flaw in
other games office Gatien is part of
what makes controls so spellbinding I'm
always glad to hear from you it's just
that I get my hopes up so many times
it's led to nothing
I found nothing if you've played
passwords from any games you will
instantly recognize the studios
footprint control story plays with grim
truths and strange themes everything is
serious except when it isn't in a dark
sense of humor creeps in for a momentary
respite the combat system is designed
for you to be equal parts agile and
destructive very notable resemblance to
the studio's microsoft exclusive quantum
break combat aside that game felt like a
step removed from what remedy does best
control feels like remedy has found its
footing again they're lying to us we are
lying to ourselves the rooms not the
world the world is much bigger and much
stranger there is one major aspect that
is decidedly new for the team control is
nonlinear built in the vein of a
Metroidvania and filled with reasons to
retrace your steps over time this
approach is largely handled well though
if there's any aspect of control that
feels lacking it's the handling of the
map it's an unreliable tool presented in
a top-down fashion that often feels like
more trouble than it's worth
multi level areas overlap with one
another you can't isolate them or zoom
in for a closer look and it's
practically impossible to track specific
locations you have or have not visited
broad areas can be tracked sure but not
say a single meeting room in the
executive branch this would be a major
issue if not for two things the signage
in the world is surprisingly helpful and
ultimately control makes wandering the
halls of the oldest house a consistent
pleasure if you aren't in awe with the
architecture you're probably getting
your kicks from a battle that pops up
when you least expect
preferring to the FBC headquarters as a
house is a bit misleading though you'll
grow to understand how in time and
practical terms is a massive multi-story
facility that screams government with
angular interiors formed in stone and
metal with minimal flourish it has the
outward appearance of an orderly place a
process which while true undersell is
the reality therein or the lack thereof
the dance between fact and fiction is at
the heart of control setting and a
fascinating narrative that unravels in
Jesse's mind through a series of inner
monologues and psychic projections she's
right as much as I don't want to admit
it
I'm the only one who can help there are
exchanges between characters that move
certain elements forward but so much of
control hinges on Jesse's discoveries
and her interpretations of their meaning
even though you're clued in to her
thoughts there's an underlying element
that jesse fails to explain because to
her its matter of fact whatever it is
has always been a part of her creating a
gap of understanding that you for the
most part can only hope to fill with
your own inferences and you entered the
building when it was already in the lock
down before you became the new director
how I'm not ready to tell her about you
yet a janitor let me deep within the
guts of the house like experiments and
studies that dig into paranormal
disturbances the collective subconscious
and alternate dimensions the FBC posits
that entities from beyond our realm have
used objects of power
ARCA typical things that we know and
take for granted as gateways into our
world
the source of this power a dimension
known as the astral plane has crept into
the Bureau and some far-off corridors
bear its telltale monochromatic
geometric motif occasionally you will
get pulled into the strange world to
undergo skill trials but your visits are
always short which helps preserve the
mystique in the long run back in the
real world
lowly agents and high-ranking FBC
enforcers have been corrupted unmask
mini float harmlessly in midair chanting
strange mantras and boardrooms hallways
and research facilities the more
aggressive of the bunch pop into
existence before your eyes as you
explore the bureau they like jesse fight
with a mix of guns and telekinetic
powers they're generally fun adversaries
and fights are punctuated by some
incredible special effects there are
only a few unique enemies and bosses to
speak of but by and large the AI in
conjunction with a great variety of
architectural layouts makes every fight
feel engaged
new powers come with story milestones
but weapon forums are crafted from
collectable materials their stats and
Jessi's increase with the application of
randomized ranked mods dropped by
enemies and found in hidden containment
chests you will likely come across
hundreds of mods but because you can
only hold and use a limited amount you
will end up dismantling most of them to
make space in your inventory mods can
make a tangible difference especially
once you start finding high ranking ones
but they can't make up for a lack of
skill or understanding of Jessi's tools
during the game's greatest tests
control is a great looking game in
general from the overall art design to
the technical execution but combat is a
notable stand out in that regard while
the experience on PC can be tuned to run
at a consistently smooth frame rate the
ps4 version can exhibit stuttering when
fights are at their most chaotic this
thankfully is an uncommon occurrence but
it definitely Clues you into how taxing
the special effects in real time physics
are with a fair amount of extra
curricular exploration it took me about
15 hours to get to the end of controls
campaign though I watched the credits
roll there are still plenty of side
quests for me to tackle Jesse isn't the
only sane person in the bureau after all
and the handful of key NPCs that
populate each sector have co-workers
gone missing or projects left abandoned
that might put the bureau at future risk
they not only give you more reasons to
spend time in Jesse's shoes but they are
great across the board brought to life
with excellent voice acting and top
notch character design
they aren't deep characters and your
conversations never go very far but I'm
more than willing to help them in their
time of need if only to see what quirky
or oddball thing they say when I return
one of my favorite aspects of control
now that I've got room to breathe is to
spend quality time with it's collectable
texts and videos I've managed to read
most of the in-game materials while
pushing through main missions and
tackling optional pursuits but there are
so many fascinating threads to pull on
and it's easy to imagine new
possibilities lying in wait if only I
studied the evidence a little closer or
considered a new angle maybe the missing
pieces of Jesse's story would come into
view these tidbits can be educational
disturbing and at times wildly
entertaining and they have inspired me
to look deeper into topics like Jungian
psychology it's similar to an iceberg
what you see is not what you always get
this place is vitally important to the
bureau
it's not often that a game invades my
thoughts the weight control has and at
the point where I want to consume every
last thing it has to offer and if I'm
honest it also makes me want to go back
and replay REM these past games - sure
it's a faulty Metroidvania in some
respects but there are so many
exceptional qualities of foot that
control handily to flex any momentary
ire
I can't wait to take part in discussions
about the game to see what others have
figured out and to better understand
where it all fits into Jesse's story
almost